[Music]
hello everybody
good good afternoon and thanks for
coming out to hear me
now if you know anything about me you
know that i work on fundamental
physics i work on quantum physics
quantum gravity
cosmology the nature of space and time
the history of the universe and so forth
and increasingly
if you've been following but it's easy
to say what i'm interested in
i'm interested in time whether time is
fundamental
real or whether it's something like
something
that is emergent that is not part of the
real fabric of the universe
and i have to say that i believe that
time is fundamental
and believing self is mean minority and
very good friends like carlo lavelli
sean
and einstein to throw him in
have asserted very vehemently the time
is not fundamental
that there exists a level of reality
below time
and if you believe that now i hope i'll
disabuse you of that
okay so the talk i'm getting is based on
very new work
which i have a new collaborator claudio
verde
but i have to thank also my longtime
collaborators
in wondering about the nature of time
julian barber
who got me started down this road marina
cortez
the brazilian philosopher roberto mangu
bear hunger
and then many other people who i've
worked with
so um i call myself a relationalist
and that means that i believe that time
and space
are not are not absolute or not
fixed for all time there is not a notion
of where something is or when something
happened
this absolute all those kinds of spatial
temporal ideas
have to do with relationships and indeed
all properties of things in the world
have to do with relationships
relationships between dynamical actors
what we physics is called degrees of
freedom
and we go back in our thinking this is
quite a tradition we go back to the
philosopher alignment
who propose a great principle of the
identity indiscernible the idea is
that if two events or two particles
have the same properties relationally
have the same set
of relations with the rest of the world
they are the same
they're not ever in the world two events
or two things
that appear to be the same but are not
and that's the key principle and we'll
see how that leads us to our views of
space and time
now the view that i'm going to develop
is a kind of elaboration
of what i think when the blindness is
original of you not that that matters it
shouldn't matter
but the universe according to liveness
according to me
is nothing but the set of partial views
of itself that is
you have a view of the world from where
you sit when you sit there
or stand or walk i have a view of the
world the martians have a view of the
world
and i'm an answer for morphizing it that
i don't need
intelligent beings or anything else
every event
in the history of the universe has a
view that's his past the events that led
up to it
and the universe is nothing but the
collection of these views
and we'll see how that idea elaborates
so i don't follow everett
and my old mentor bryce to williton john
wheeler great scientist as they were
in saying that we have one wave function
which describes many universes
i can't make sense of that idea what i'm
going to tell you is that there are many
partial views
to describe a single universe and we
don't have in science
many universes we have one universe
and that universe is what it is it has
the properties it has it has the
peculiarities it has it might have been
different it might have been a different
universe
but there is only one universe and
that's what we
scientists and philosophers want to
explain
not to generality universes but just the
one universe
in which we find ourselves
so i've been thinking about these things
for a long time
and it's good to get shaken up it's good
to have a new point of view
and the following is a new point of view
and this is the first time
these ideas are exposed they were
developed
with chelya clever day and
we'll see how they go over i think the
ideas
are radical but they're not difficult
to understand and appreciate and i hope
you will
so let's start by saying something we
all know
quantum mechanics asserts that many
questions about nature
have indefinite answers if we ask if we
have a radioactive nuclei in a box here
and we know that the half-life is two
days
that's what quantum mechanics tells us a
statistical prediction
but when within the two days or within
the next weeks and months
with that particular radioactive nuclear
decay
it's indefinite quantum mechanics
doesn't tell us this causes us
probabilities
when it does decay it makes a neutrino
what direction will the neutrino go off
well the quantum mechanics gives us
probabilities for different directions
it doesn't tell us it's indefinite
when we look if we look for an electron
in the atom of that nuclei
where will we find it quantum mechanics
gives us the wave function this
beautiful kind of contrast picture which
gives us the probabilities to find the
electron in different places
but it only gives us the probabilities
it's indefinite
and the electron has a spin and will
that spin be up or down if we measure it
again quantum mechanics just gives us
probabilities so many things in nature
according to quantum mechanics are
indefinite
and notice something these are all
questions about the future
well let's keep going other questions
are definite
what time did the nuclear decay it
decayed sometime
yesterday let's say what time was it
when it decayed
well there is a definite answer it's
decayed at 7 26
a.m when it decayed which direction did
neutrino run often
well there's an answer it ran off north
northwest
when we looked where did we find the
electron in the hydrogen atom
two or three angstroms due north from
the nuclei
etc what was the spin when we measured
it last tuesday was it up or down
gives us a definite answer to notice
something about these questions and if
i could see you and we could do an
interaction i would ask you to shout out
the answer
but maybe maybe i'll hear if people
shout really loud
these are all questions about the past
now is this
important we've been learned we've been
told by
numerous physicists and philosophers
that there's no difference between the
past and the future or the present
the just points of view to just where we
are
from just like it doesn't matter
fundamentally
whether or not in toronto or new york or
london or paris or istanbul
or from tokyo it's not supposed to
matter whether it's thursday or next
tuesday
to what physics what the laws of nature
are
to what the physical theories are but
i'm saying here
i'm noticing that when we use quantum
mechanics as experimentalists
we use it for real when we're talking
about things that are indefinite
we're talking about the future we're
talking about things that are in-depth
that are definite
we're talking about the past whose
future and who's past
mind and lures in the moment
so this calls to mind the philosophy of
time
it's not too popular among scientists
but it's very well discussed among
philosophers
called presentism now this is not
exactly presentism
if you know what that is and you'll see
that as we move forward
and even look at my metaphor move
forward
but we're going to try to take seriously
what it means to build a science around
a world in which in fact it means
something
whether you're the future of the past
well the first thing you might say is
well if everything is
definite eventually then what about the
uncertainty principle
it doesn't matter everything can be
definite in the past and it doesn't
affect the uncertainty principle
in fact warner heisenberg who invented
the uncertainty principles
thought about this and said this
formulation makes it clear
that the uncertainty relation does not
refer to the past
so if there's something wrong with
talking about the past and future
werner heisenberg was at fault as well
not just myself and clevia
and a few other people so what do we
mean when we're talking about the future
and the past
well ernest schwarzenegger also
recognized the distinction between the
present the future and
the past and this is just a small part
of a quote
the larger quote i have to confess i
find hard to parse
you go looking for it he seems to be
wanting to dissolve
in an orgy of erotic whatever with the
universe
stronger was kind of strange guy but
here he's endorsing this view which is
called
presentism that for eternally and always
there is only now
one and the same now the present is the
only thing
that has no end and then longer quote
let's look for somebody sensible not
such a romantic
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
it's